ما حقيقه هديه ميسي لزملائه فيفا يفاوض
لشراء ملعب في فرنسا مورينيو يؤثر المشاكل
في درب الصغار هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعون
على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
انتشر خبر صباح اليوم على السوشيال ميديا
مفاده ان ميسي اهدى زملائه اجهزه ايفون
مطليه بالذهب بقيمه 200 الف دولار الخبر
غير صحيح حيث لم ينشر ميسي او اي لاعب من
المنتخب صوره للجهاز على مواقع التواصل في
الحقيقه الاجهزه هي هديه من شركه اي
ديزاين جولد وهذا بحسب ما اعلنت الشركه
عبر صفحتي على الانستقرام كما نشرت صوره
لرئيس التنفيذي مع قاعده الارجنتين ليو
ميسي
اكدت صحيفه ليكي بالفرنسيه عن وجود
مفاوضات بين الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
والسلطات في فرنسا لشراء ملعب ستاد فرانس
الخاص بالمنتخب وبحسب تقارير الصحفيه
محليه فان كيف يسعى من ورائي هذه الصفقه
لاقامه بعض المباريات الكبرى في العاصمه
باريس واستضافه مباريات في الحالات
الطارئه مثل مباريات منتخب اوكرانيا او
استخدامه كارض محايده
بعد يومين فقط من طرده بمسابقه الدوري
اعاد جوزي مورينيو لاثاره الجدل هذه المره
في دربي روما اللي اقل من 14 عاما المدرب
البرتغالي قام بالتصفير على لاعب اثناء
تقدمه للتنفيذ ركله جزاء كما طلب من لاعبي
فريق روما وسقوط على الارض وادعاء الاصابه
لاضاعه الوقت وانهى مورينيو بالتقاط صوره
تذكاريه مع لاعبي الفريق الصغار بعد الفوز
في المباراه
اعلنا نادي برشلونه الاسباني توقيعه لعقد
مع ابن رونالدينيو وجاء هذا الاعلان بعد
اسبوعين فقط من خوض جواوي لمباراه وديه
بقميص الفريق الكاتلوني توقيع العقد
الجديد بين الطرفين تم بحضور عضو مجلس
الاداره جوان سولار والمدير الرياضي جوزي
وببتسامه عريضه من الابن تشبه ابتسامه
الساحر رونالدينيو